hi there steve kaufman here uh the sun's
starting to come out after several days
of rain here in vancouver so i got my
golf shirt on
i want to talk about linguistics
and universal grammar
and respond to some of the comments that
have been uh
put on my uh you know underneath some of
my videos about linguistics
um why am i so or appear to be so anti
anti-intellectual i guess that's the
frequent sort of theme of the people
that come at me well first of all let me
say that i'm not anti-intellectual i
like to read i have in fact read a lot
of books about linguistics
and about language learning and i'm
going to show you some of them
but i also like to keep things simple
the old occam's razor theory if there is
an easy explanation and a complicated
explanation
i prefer the easy one
i think that language learning is just a
matter of exposing yourself to the
language
that if you as i've said many many times
i won't go back into it again that's how
the child learns the adult has the
advantage that they can read and write
love to read and that the adult has a
lot of experience has a lot of
vocabulary in his own or her own
language
but essentially we observe the language
the for the brain forms uh patterns and
eventually we start to be able to speak
and the more we speak the better we get
know the child doesn't get corrected all
the time we don't need to get corrected
all the time but it can help so not
against it but just just have a look at
i just went up to my
you know where i keep all my books to
see what i had what i'd read over the
last you know seven or eight years years
since i got interested in this subject
so first of all we have crash foreign
language education the easy way
thin book excellent book hardly
recommended that's not to say i agree
with everything there but i recommend it
now here we have
the cambridge guide to teaching english
to speakers of other languages
basically i didn't find much in there
that was useful because it over
complicates things uh what else do we
have here the practice of english
language teaching by jeremy harmer okay
i've read that book
um second second language acquisition by
rod ellis okay again some good stuff
some bad stuff
second language vocabulary acquisition
james cody thomas hucken i prefer the
way we do it at link
language teaching methodology a textbook
for teachers david noonan all right
how about this vocabulary in language
teaching norbert schmidt
again none of this stuff really
influenced very much what we do
at link probably the best book i read on
vocabulary was
learning vocabulary in another language
by mr nation nation nation
all right
how languages are learned patsy
lightbound nina spada
all right
again my overwhelming impression
of all these books is that they were too
complicated
so i also read books about the brain
uh an excellent book the mind and the
brain how our will and our determination
can influence what happens in the brain
even though of course our will and
determination itself are phenomena of
the brain so to speak i like reading in
different languages das gehen which was
nowhere near as good as lernen by
manfred pitzer which i have often
referred to which was very good about
the cognitive process and the brain and
i find these books much more useful
than the
linguistics books but
i have not ignored the linguistics so
i've read by rh robbins a short history
of linguistics with a chinese intro i
bought it in beijing because every time
i travel i go to bookstores
uh in stockholm i bought a book les
affordandes broke about reading and how
we can improve reading in a foreign
language
uh
i
dislike social linguistics but i want to
understand what it's all about so i
bought a book by bonnie norton called
identity and language learning gender
ethnicity and educational change didn't
influence what we do at link i can tell
you that
then i read this book by uh julia
christie
okay because i happen to be on holiday
in uh
near uh pole at uh
near pole for two weeks so i went to the
bookstore and bought books on
linguistics in french here here is an
excellent book
and it has a number of leading french
linguistics experts who amongst other
things tear chomsky's universal grammar
apart all right
i can quote from there if someone's
interested
essay the language
luigi calve interesting from a
sociolinguistic perspective but also not
strong on chomskins chomsky's universal
grammar
de los recuerdos because i'm always
interested in you know how we remember
things and stuff like that i had a bit
of a spat with claude aj in french and i
consider him a french language
chauvinist and this book le francais
is interesting in terms of describing a
history of french but of course he gets
carried away with the whole glorious
expansion of the french language and now
it's retreat in the face of the english
onslaught
to understand is to invent the future of
education jean piaget
of course more on language and
chomskyist
disciples like stephen pinker's the
language instinct
what else we got again it's nice to read
the same read about the same subject you
know in different ways so this teach
yourself book on linguistics
um what else i do subscribe to the
foreign to the american council on
teaching a foreign languages report
which i must say don't read very much it
only confirms my sense that things are
over complicated i just happen to pull
down this cd here and i strongly
recommend that anyone who really wants
to get good at languages do a lot of
listening and get to where you can
listen to real literature things that
are of interest to you where you can
also access the text
so
basically what i'm trying to say is i
read
but i don't buy it i think that i don't
buy this over complication like a fellow
that just posted on my uh youtube
channel about
the video that i did on vocabulary it's
over simplification i need to be parsing
uh and he misunderstood what i said of
course i didn't say that you just
learned the few words and phrases i i
don't have it handy so i can't quote it
oh here he is he he criticizes my uh
video on vocabulary he says more
aggressive discouraging of high
standards and excellence well what are
your standards i haven't heard you speak
some foreign language whoever you are
here brand of costumes
uh is his name basic phrases and
vocabulary usually learned at the
beginning no i'm not talking about basic
phrases and vocabulary i'm saying that
the process of language learning is a
long road and you begin by learning a
few uh you know the basic words and
phrases which are easily learned
but thereafter there's a long long road
as you pick up the the
large number of words that make up the
20 percent
lower frequency words that you need in
order to be comfortable in any context
it's a long road
and you know you don't have any way to
parse them i don't want to parse them
unless you have studied morphology i
don't even know what morphology is and i
i mean i know but i'm not interested in
morphology i'm interested in learning
the language from the language and
enjoying myself listening reading and
starting then to talk and enjoy the
language and i know that the brain will
pick it up that way i don't need to
parse i don't need to know what
morphology is
uh blah blah blah ironic that you think
an l1 gloss constitutes their meaning i
don't i think that the quickest
uh
hint to what the word means is the
translation into my own language and
especially at the beginning where i
couldn't read a turkish explanation of
what a horse is
whereas if it says horse i know what a
horse is but i also know that for most
of these words i have to see them again
and again in different context to get a
full sense of what they mean and how
they're used
you ignore the intricate complex
complexities of rule-governed behavior
of the hierarchical system
what you know
the brain will get used to it and one
other thing i want to say why i am i'll
probably run over the 10 minutes but
the problem why i so
disagree with this approach of universal
grammar is that most of the people who
write on universal grammar and most of
the references that i've seen to it in
french in english and other languages
involve people talking about the
languages that they know typically
french english spanish italian
and describing the phenomena that they
just they see in those languages and
explaining why there's this underlying
universal uh set of rules even though
superficially they may look different
but
what is language
uh in japanese for example that people
don't talk and even in like in in
russian you don't have to have a verb
in a sentence this book means
this is a book
so there's no is no end this book this
is the book in japanese people say uh
you know
just means go that means are you going
they just say
japanese person knows how was it didn't
mean how did you go it means how was it
now there is the whole range of
communication with words that are not
said that's still language
and in some languages
that is in fact the way communication
takes place very simplified and in some
languages you have a more formal
structure and an informal structure and
both the informal the very informal and
or the very formal can be quite cryptic
and quite short and it's still language
and it's still communication and so and
of course these things evolve the
relationship between words evolve the
if you want grammatical function of
words evolved the meaning of words
evolves
you know again getting back to to
the japanese i mean there you have have
um
you know adjectives that are in the past
tense
there's no verb there is yokatta
you know
good has a past tense
i just can't see where there's any
underlying structure and and whoever
writes on language
about a universal grammar may know five
languages ten languages they don't know
three thousand
six thousand languages
so um and and i understand too that that
one of uh
chomsky's reasons for assuming there was
a universal grammar was otherwise he
said how could you explain that children
uh learn to speak so quickly well they
don't learn to speak so quickly they
spend an awful long time hearing the
language they're even exposed to the
language in the womb
so
and when they start speaking they
stumble
and they gradually through trial and
error
you know pick up on the pattern of the
language that surrounds them
which you know could be
spoken in more complete sentences
in some languages or in some
environments or could be spoken in very
basic
forms of communication where a lot of
other stuff
outside the language is understood
so
i guess what i'm saying is that i enjoy
languages i enjoy learning them uh when
i start new languages i will at link
we're going to introduce new languages
uh czech dodge you know indonesian
i just want to go at them
and and uh read and listen and and look
up with their little uh you know with
the online dictionary create flash cards
um
yeah explanations will help me because
i'm an adult
but my ability to understand the
explanations is limited so we are going
to introduce notes pages so that our
members can provide some explanation and
i may refer to that and and and then go
back and refer to it again and it'll be
part of the whole process of gradually
absorbing the language without parsing
without morphology without whatever else
was in that thing and uh and so
you know and when i pick up i don't know
like the language instinct and i see
these diagrams that so i'll just happen
to have it here you know all these
diagrams and stuff like that i tell you
my eyes just
glass over
uh
you know s
dash np vp sense can consist of a noun
phrase and a verb phrase do these terms
actually mean anything in in terms of
other languages this was the thing i
found learning chinese a bunch of
grammatical terms from from western
european languages that had had no
relevance for for japanese and chinese
anyway enough this is quite a long one
and um i will leave you with that and i
look forward to the continuing comments
and i must say that some of the
linguistics i don't want to knock
linguistics and everyone who studies
linguistics i think it's very
interesting to study the history of
different languages and how they're
related and how they develop
and uh and if people are interested
they're interested in it so it's perfect
legitimate in that sense it's just that
uh when people come at me and say that
you can't learn the language if you
don't parse if you don't know what
phonemes and morphemes and all this
other stuff
uh r
is are these things are
then you know and you shouldn't be
starting off on how to learn languages
because you're a fool and you're
anti-intellectual and stuff so i
appreciate the
linguists in the sense of linguistics
specialist who have commented in a in a
nice tone uh here at my uh at my uh
youtube channel and i look forward to
seeing further comments thank you